Russian air and sea activity around UK
waters has increased dramatically in
recent years
it is back up at Cold War levels and it
is getting worse this is a resurgence
that has come very quickly it is an
intensifying resurgence of capability
and scale that we didn't necessarily see
coming maybe ten years ago in his first
major television interview the First Sea
Lord told me how the Royal Navy is now
establishing an official joint area of
operations in the North Atlantic it will
make the region a priority for Britain's
armed forces means ships and planes are
deployed there much more regularly in
future one of their tasks will be to
protect the vital undersea lines we are
aware that the Russians have the
capability to detect and work on those
cables and of course they're doing this
in very difficult environmental
conditions of very great depths it's not
easy to work out exactly what's going on
an estimated 97% of global
communications are transmitted by these
fiber-optic cables they run thousands of
meters below the sea right around the
world and carry 10 trillion dollars in
daily financial transactions if they
were cut it could be devastating the
very fact that they are going to where
we know the cables are and are using
vessels that are coming away from the
mothership in order to get close to the
cables is a sign that they are at the
very least surveying them and
potentially looking to be able to do
operations more than that NATO leaders
meet in Brussels this week Russia and
the threat to Europe will be high on the
agenda the Alliance's original founding
role securing the North Atlantic area is
once again the major priority Alister
bunka Sky News